this is interesting because we've talked
about it's like the mouse Utopia the
right Utopia experiment basically this
dude put a bunch of mice in this big in
this big space and gave him all the food
and water they could want and then just
left there you go Utopia everything
you'd ever want and eventually they
their society broke down some became
aggressive some stopped procreating
there there were some they were called
the beautiful ones uh Shane Cashman
wrote about this beautiful ones of
universe 25 that they would just groom
themselves all day and just make
themselves look prettier and pretty they
won't mate they're just themselves they
won't mate but the male rats will still
have sex
well they would they were like all
cluster in one room together like
there's this their social order broke
down they just stopped functioning
properly and then eventually they all
died
and uh it sounds a lot like what we're
seeing now like there is a there is a
limit to Live and Let Live I guess like
obviously fascism is bad okay people
need to have freedom in leeway to live
their lives and be productive but then
if you get to the point where you're
like you literally don't care that adult
entertainers are putting on Children's
shows like adult entertainment for kids
is bad obviously but the left the
Liberals they're cheering for it it's
like okay I think we're entering the rat
Utopia phase where our society ceases to
exist I guess the difference is
we have we can see it and we know the
results of these experiments so I think
worst case scenario
Society breaks down completely people
become aggressive and start killing each
other which kind of seems like it's
happening and then Preppers who are
active pay attention and read build
bunkers ranches and then humans are just
they end up fine in the long run yeah we
get through I think I think you see
people withdraw from society right I
mean you talk about this all time
leaving cities we know a lot of people
who switched homeschooling during the
pandemic they decide that they don't
want to be a part of the society so they
sort of as much as possible with
throughout especially it's not it's not
totally possible you still use the
grocery store your kids still have
friends who go to public school that
kind of stuff but they actively choose
to try and put distance between them and
what are signs of society's collapse
yeah well it's it's what you said uh Tim
about in the beginning about having
everything in the convenience culture
has evolved to the point where we don't
need human relationships we have
everything we need you know we we don't
need you know relationships to gratify
our sexual urges which is very innate in
us we have pornography we don't need to
make our own food we have ubereats and
we just have grocery stores where we
pick it off the shelves we don't have
danger to make us need physical fitness
and endurance and you know fighting off
dangers we literally don't need each
other anymore and that is killing us
dude you want to hear something really
crazy I make millions of dollars
complaining about on the
internet and I I am astounded every
single day because I grew up in a way I
grew up in a place where I was like if
you don't work you don't eat and I'm in
the city it's like I I I I would play
guitar in the subway when I'm basically
borderline homeless because I'm like I'm
gonna find a way to make money other
otherwise I'm not eating and that's what
you had to do and now I'm at a point
where it's like turn the camera on
complain people listen and you make
money doing it I'm not saying that to be
self-deprecating for the most part I'm
saying there isn't we have we have as a
society gotten to the point where there
are people who don't actually work
and they live like kings this is the
craziest thing like we're all Kings now
this is not this is not feasible in the
long run it is not a viable way for
Human Society to function that right now
there are people whose hands are covered
in in or their hands are calloused and
every day they're lifting things they're
constructing things and they make
substantially less than a buzzfeed
writer there is a person who works at
BuzzFeed well not anymore they're
replacing it with AI it's going to get
even worse I guess or maybe maybe better
maybe people will be forced to start
working again but there are people who
work in the corporate press who show up
to work in the morning and they're like
uh what should we do today
um You can call Trump a Nazi and they're
like okay yeah I'll do that and then
they make 90 000 a year meanwhile people
at home listening are like I drove a car
around for 12 hours you know doing
deliveries and I made 50 to 100 bucks
how can a society function when you have
a class of when you have working class
actual working class people who work and
then you have the elite ruling class and
corporate press that do nothing and
extract 10 times the value from the
system now that is a recipe for disaster
in my opinion that can't sustain itself
yeah I mean when you talk about
animosity like that that'll fuel
animosity to him
um and I think that some of the things
we mentioned aren't accessible to the
people who are making you know 50 to 100
a day the BuzzFeed writer can spend all
day on the internet and can get ubereats
and whatever else but if you live in a
rural community and you don't have the
budget for that you are forced to
interact with your your neighbors and
your world a little bit more and I think
that is one of the reasons it's so
separate I know I mentioned a couple
times but the CDC released their youth
Behavior study and they found basically
that teenage girls are really unha the
majority of teen girl is very sad very
unhappy who are the most social
creatures naturally on Earth teenage
girls they look for Community all they
want to do is talk to friends but their
society more and more is digital right
teens are on their phones they're
interacting on Snapchat they are looking
for gratification through likes on
Instagram as opposed to in-person
accomplishments we are leading them into
their own destruction and we're just
saying no it's great because we have
comfort now and it's so nice the
internet I think it's I think it's funny
that it's I think it's funny that it's
the wealthy trust fund lefties that
think they're the oppressed working
class you know there's like that viral
video out of I think it was Seattle
where a bunch of anti-amazon protesters
are you know leftists are protesting and
then the actual Amazon workers show up
in hard hats and like vests and they
start shouting them down like the actual
working class guy is like a 35 year old
white dude named John who voted for
Trump not a you know 30 year old hipster
named Devlin who you know took feminist
basket weaving at college but they think
their working class and they live in
cities their lives are funded by this is
the craziest thing to me about how the
system works college loans right now
everyone's screaming like Joe Biden pay
off our loans oh no the loan forgiveness
and you've got these these protesters
these unions and they're screaming being
like they need to forgive student loans
and I'm like it's just crazy to me that
these hipster leftist types literally do
no work get free money from these
institutions then demand everyone else
eat the cost and pay for their entitled
lives and there's a dude out there right
now who's listening to this show at work
lifting a heavy box and his back hurts
and he's thinking yep that's but that
the the thing is they don't think that
they're the working class they're
they're leninists and they think that
they're the Vanguard they they really do
they they're Marxist leninists that's
where that's the basics of their their
opinion they're the ones that are the
the Bourgeois they're the bourgeoiselle
yeah they're the Bourgeois that are
gonna they're the Bourgeois Pro that are
gonna that are gonna sweep the
proletariat through the revolution into
the new Society into the social Society
that's exactly what they think everyone
that's that's at Media Matters thinks
that they're a member of the Vanguard
they're all going to get the bullet if
they get what they want because that's
what the commies do oh yeah the the
Communists Purge the Intelligentsia that
fell into the revolution in the first
place yeah liberal let's get the bullet
too so they're done but but the
Communists know who's a real risk the
working class guy or the Revolutionary
the Revolutionary so once the revolution
happens the revolutionize turn on each
other but I got an idea here's what we
should do we should do one of those like
panel discussions that you see on the
internet every so often where they'll
get like you know two layers of chairs
and then have people all sit there and
like a person ask them all questions and
I just want to get like working class
Union guys from Western Maryland and
West Virginia and then College hipster
leftists and then just be like let me
ask you guys some questions who did you
vote for and then watch all the working
class guys be like oh yeah I work in a
factory I work in a steel mill I voted
for Trump and then the college student
is going to be like but you're working
class why are you voting for Trump I
voted for Biden it's like you have no
idea our problems dude but this this is
the fundament fundamental difference
between the left and the right the left
base the left bases their life around
rights where the right bases their life
around obligations and that's what the
left does is they say you have all of
these rights and if you vote for me I
will give them to you and the right
things I don't have rights the only
rights I have is the right to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness I
have an obligation to my family I have
an obligation to God I have an
obligation to my country I would say the
left promise isn't settlements they
would say things like you deserve this
this is yours but they frame it as
rights they you have a right to Health
Care you have a right to food you have a
right to this wage you have a right to
everything a hundred years ago we we
only had those three rights the right to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness you need it to build you need
it to farm you needed to fight and
because we don't have the need to do all
those things they can come up with all
these rights and then again say you have
these rights and if you vote for me I
will give them to you I will I will give
you all of your desires that again comes
back to the fact that they're not
liberals they're they're progressives
they believe that they don't believe in
rights at all they don't believe in in
the rights are what the government gives
to people and that's all they believe I
just part of me really would love it if
the system just stopped for one month
just one month but but I know the
reality is a lot of people would die and
I don't want that to happen I just want
these purple hair shaved head leftists
who cry because someone misgendered them
I just want them to understand a little
bit what hard work really is and how
hard life really is for other people
because while these people are at
Starbucks crying because someone
misgendered them there is a 12 year old
kid mining Cobalt with his teeth falling
out of his face who's doing the work to
make sure they can have their espresso
machine and they have no idea they are
these people exemplify capital city in
The Hunger Games so perfectly they don't
realize that they watch these movies and
they're like I'm Katniss and like no no
you're that Capital City crazy haired
lady drinking ipicac and barfing to eat
more food at your party not realizing
other people are being beaten and
enslaved so they can sustain your way of
life I think that there are other people
too even in these colleges I one of my
good friends growing up or that I went
to high school with put himself through
college while working as an EMT tea full
time and he got his degree and he kept
going like he's one of the hardest
working people I know and I think if
anyone in his college had been like I'm
working class too he would have laughed
but he wouldn't have said anything
because what he doesn't need to prove
himself to them I think that the people
who have never been asked to consider
like they you know they take on student
loan debt knowing that someone in their
family will be able to help them pay it
off or they don't need to think about it
they are resigned to not being
responsible for the consequences of
their actions and then when eventually
they are at they're put in a position
where they have to act with
responsibility or to meet their
obligations they don't want to do it
anymore this is the problem though
there's a there probably conservative
types with Cal's hands sit there with a
smile on their face looking at the
hippie liberal being like If Only They
Knew man a whiny little you know whiny
little and they don't say
anything
and it's because they're hardened and
they're not phased by the complaints of
these people but the squeaky wheel gets
the grease so these lunatic leftists go
around smashing things and screaming and
then
feckless politicians are like just give
them whatever they want they're yelling
in my ears yeah I saw a tick tock I saw
a tick tock the other day some kid was
literally saying why do I have to work
just to live oh my gosh and I'm like
really oxidization that's what I say
oxidization I'll try and get it to the
root for you dude it's called entropy
that's it your body is is ceasing to
exist without being sustained by energy
and you have to get it from somewhere
ain't nobody can do it for you it's
amazing that people think that there was
a meme that went around for a while that
was like I blame my parents for this I
didn't ask to be born so I didn't ask to
like pay for all this anyway
you're gonna be like so you'd rather be
dead like what that's why they're
footballing yeah they are foreign
they're also saying that like they
should never have to assume
responsibility right like life is a gift
and being able to live life on Earth is
something is a blessing and so therefore
like don't look at your parents be like
how could you do this to me how could
you bring me on like into this world be
grateful and become mature and accept
your responsibilities in life
I forget the Philosopher's name but he's
like this is not some kind of new thing
that there was a philosopher hundreds of
years ago talking about the flungness of
existence the the the way that you kind
of just are tossed into reality like
that's part of the human condition shut
the hell up and quit whining no it
pisses me off when I go online and I see
people my age and they're like I had
such a hard day at school like I just
need to unwind it's like what do you
mean unwind you read books for six hours
unwind for what can you imagine like
talking to a 50 year old guy that's been
working on the docs in the 60s he comes
home and you're like how was your day
like how are you feeling he'd look at
you and you go what do you mean how am I
feeling I need to put food on the table
what do you mean I gotta get up in eight
hours are you kidding me but we have
this sense of entitlement in my
generation that yeah you need to have
your relaxation time you need to have
your vacation time you need to have a
little cookie at the end of your meal
you need a little sweetness it's like no
no you have obligations to again your
God country and your family and the left
has stripped all those things away and
said you have all these rights you are
the government is your daddy
and it's left everybody sad depressed
anxious like obligation and working for
people outside of yourself working for a
higher power working for things anything
outside of yourself that's what gives
you fulfillment that's what gives you
gratitude that's what gives you a
meaningful life thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time